que fait quasiment qui devait être être
là puis une demi heure
pas très chers amis bonjour à monsieur
19 je suis contente de vous voir à le
très gentil ma chère amie voyez-vous ce
qui est agréable c'est vous c'est que
vous trouvez toujours le mot qu'il faut
au moment où il le faut je suis très
content mais pourquoi me dire ça mais
voilà je n'ai pas beaucoup envie de
travailler ce matin elle votre sueur et
votre façon de me dire c'est content de
vous voir a réveillé en moi dans un
grand élan de générosité une grande
envie de travailler et il vient vous
avez de la chance mais c'est l'islam
sport oui je pense que kazimi on n'est
pas dans votre cas je lui ai demandé de
venir pour faire quelques mouvements de
bars et de gymnastique au sol et il
n'est toujours pas arrivé bonjour je lis
bonjour menant du sein en casimir et
mont boukehil y ait eu en retard il ya
une demi heure que je t'attends enfin ce
n'est pas de ma faute mais c'est la
faute de qui s'il te plaît
des indiens des zincs royer alors je ne
comprends vraiment pas vous dire ma
chère amie kat casimir est une surprise
permanent alors explique nous poser la
faute des alliances mais maintenant tout
ghazi m'affirmait que les indiens ne
connaissent pas la danse classique et
moi je lui est certifié le contraire
mais tu as raison casimir aujourd'hui
dans tous les pays du monde la danse
classique est connue et très appréciée
si vous permettez moi chers amis je
pense que là tant de casimir n'a pas
tout à fait tort ça m'aurait étonné que
vous ne preniez pas un parti de cette
pêche n'est que voulez vous dire
monsieur du snob et bien voilà tous les
pays connaissent la danse classique mais
je pense que chacun d'eux a au moins une
danse qui lui est propre à dans ce sens
là vous avez aussi raison monsieur du
snav et vous connaissez beaucoup de ces
danses ou que le 12 août
mais nombreux contacts avec la haute
société de ces pays
bien sûr casimir et toi tu reconnais
aubin si monsieur du snarr bon avec
capable de ça moi aussi oui bon alors
vous allez me faire tous les deux une
démonstration devant les enfants
en mai c'est à dire que je vais au moins
ça tombe bien parce que je suis et je
comprends j'ai affaire à deux vantard
heureusement qu'il ya aujourd'hui dans
l'île le plus grand professeur du monde
de danse le plus grand professeur du
monde mais d'extraordinaire
les venues spécialement de russie
d'ailleurs le voilà qu'arrive je vous
présente monsieur papa bonjour bonjour
tu eu raison dans les petites julie avez
vous fait un bon voyage
votre potentiel grande échelle voyage
petit julie est ce que vous pouvez nous
donner un cours de danse à tous tout de
suite au-dessus du tout du sud
cher monsieur pouf pouf 12e qui perd
juste nos cousines
pardonnez moi monsieur une peau propre
assiette jean louis c'est un grand
honneur pour moi de vous rencontrer
j'aimerais bien pouvoir prendre le thé
c'est une amie à moi une comtesse je me
suis dit snap ce n'est pas le moment
pardonnez moi il faut toujours qu'il se
fasse remarquer celui là il est pr peu
près près et chercher les enfants
monsieur propose ya dix ans allez petit
gibier sur venez les enfants s'ils
venaient écouter super pop 11e expliqué
ray cloud casimir et petites heures du
snob vont danser pour vous différentes
danses de plusieurs pays
ni pays d'origine de ces musiques de
danses ou bien compris en ce compris
s'il vous plaît
ouais manque d'honneur réponse oui si
difficile à dire
c'était la russie écoutez une autre dos
[Musique]
dans ce cas
on
et pas mal du tout pas mal du tout
réponse dans une danse française
la française anna d'allemands ou de
réponse m'a donné la réponse est dense
sur le tapis danse de graisse écoute
écoute et une autres mousses
m
alors les yeux passé vérité offre serait
pas aussi avec tabanou s'est produit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
menu vrille merveilleux casimir jaton
[Musique]
j'ai entendu bonnes réponses c'est une
danse des pays arabes
écoutez une autre étape
[Musique]
je vous remercie beaucoup monsieur
propose hier mais c'était un plaisir
surhumain c'était très bien françois tu
m'as reconnu e tu m'as reconnu
bien sûr comment as tu fais ton
imitation professeur russe était
pourtant parfaite sans limitation de
professeurs on s'était peut-être très
bien il était tellement mauvais comme
professeur de danse que j'ai tout de
suite compris que c'était 8 aux communes
[Musique]